- Let's get into our conversation
with a Los Angeles native
and an incredible human being,
someone who can speak
to this city so much,
she wrote a real love letter herself
to this beautiful place.
It's Billie Eilish.
(audience applauding and cheering)
I watched your documentary.
I've been following you for
as long as I can remember.
And there there's a moment in your concert
when you snap your ankle
and you walk off stage
and you come out and this
is one of the reasons
why I'm so in love with
you is because you say,
"Look, I just want to
do it a certain way."
And people don't know how
to usually be so honest
in those moments.
How do you just say it like it is?
How do you know to do that?
That is such an art.
- You know, I've always been very,
very strong-willed and honest,
which I think is like
a blessing and a curse.
But the funny thing is that (chuckles)
the older I've gotten the
less confident I've gotten
and it kind of made me like almost...
'Cause I rewatched the
doc like a few weeks ago
and it made me cry\ because I was thinking
how like free spirited I was
and how open-minded I was,
and then it's like the media
just like tears it away from you.
And it's like it's not fun right now
so it's like I'm trying-
- I know.
- I know, I'm trying
to like, I don't know.
But I'm figuring it out.
- Believe me, I get it.
(Billie chuckling)
And I have such faith that you will
because even when you're struggling,
you're aware of the struggle.
You said something that really
struck me in the documentary.
You really have this issue
with the word "fans."
And I was wondering where that stems from.
- I think that the reason
that it was so weird to me
was because one moment I
was a fan and then suddenly
I was looked at as this
like higher up suddenly,
even when I was 14 and it was so weird
because I was like "I'm not
even anyone, I just make music"
and these kids that I
feel like I already know
suddenly like, oh, they're Billie's fans
and then there's Billie.
And so that's why it was so weird to me
but I think of them as
like literally my skin,
like part of me and like
how I get through stuff
and you know, they always have my back
and like they're fans
just as much as I'm a fan,
but that doesn't make them any
less than me or anybody else.
You know?
- Now one of the things
that I'm also so in love with
you for is your directing.
Why did you know that you would
be the one to take control
and get your vision across?
- I mean, I've always, I've
always had the ideas already.
I just didn't really know
that I could do them myself
for awhile, but then after
awhile I was just like,
"You know what?
I want to do this," because
I think I've realized
that this is what I've
wanted to do all along
and I can actually, like
I have to prove myself
and I really had to prove myself
because who's gonna trust
a little 15 year old kid
that doesn't have any experience at all?
But I did and it's been like-
- Someone did.
- Yeah. The best decision ever.
Ever, ever.
- And kind of like, you know,
do you know Pippi Longstocking?
- Yeah.
Hell yeah.
- The Go-Go's Beauty and the Beat album
and Pippi Longstocking
were like these two things
that collided in my world
when I was a little girl
right here in Los Angeles.
And they both showed me
that I could do anything,
it didn't matter that I was a girl
and I didn't have to become
a man or a man hater.,
I could be all things girl,
but I could do anything.
- Yeah.
- And I loved how personal
you were about the marketing
and putting out of your album.
How are you feeling about this
album being out there now?
How does it feel?
- It feels good.
I was very, very, very nervous
and very worried and anxious.
'Cause also, you know,
sophomore album is like,
has more pressure than the first one,
especially if people
really liked the first one
and it's my favorite thing in the world
and I have so much trust and
love shoved into this project.
And I mean, it's terrifying
that it's out in the world.
It couldn't be scarier to me,
but I'm also very happy and
pleased and hope that, you know,
people can actually listen to the lyrics
and actually understand them
and listen to me (chuckles)
and contribute it to their own life
and like put it in their own situations
and I hope that it helps people
and just makes them make
a difference in their life
and change something in their life
that's been bothering them or something
because that's what music is for.
- Well, I love you.
And I will be going to bed
tonight as I usually do
playing the PJ party video in my head
and usually I'm there with you girls like.
- Oh my God, can we just...
Can we just be best friends, please?
- I would love it.
- I love you so much.
This is an insanely
like surreal interview.
I don't know why it's a big deal for you
because it's an insanely
enormous deal for me
and you're Drew Barrymore so shut up.
(laughing)
- Thank you guys so much.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Her new album "Happier
Than Ever" is available now
and accompanied by her
cinematic concert experience,
"Happier Than Ever: A Love
Letter to Los Angeles,"
which is available on Disney Plus.
I'm gonna say something
directly to Billie.
You deserve to be happier than ever.
It is a privilege to
watch you on your journey.
You bring tears to my eyes
at how much I love you.
Thank you for allowing me
to have a great conversation with you.
(upbeat music)